[Música]
como lo decía previamente nos acompaña
nuestro primer invitado del día Eduardo
Gutiérrez editor de realeza de la
revista quién en México señor Gutiérrez
Bienvenido a France 24 hemos visto un
funeral histórico que cierra el luto
nacional en honor a Isabel segunda que
le espera a la monarquía británica ahora
cómo estás Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación Un saludo para ti por
supuesto para toda tu audiencia Pues
bueno lo que le espera es precisamente
la cara hacia el futuro realmente todos
los británicos están hoy interesados en
ver cómo será este gobierno que
ciertamente podemos llamar de transición
debido a la edad que tiene el príncipe
Carlos más bien el Rey Carlos III y
bueno Pues habrá que decirlo también la
gente tiene esta esperanza fijada en lo
que podrá ser el nuevo reinado más más
longevo que sería el del actual príncipe
de gales William y la esperanza que se
tiene precisamente Pues por toda la
herencia cultural que se tiene con él
por haber sido hijo de una de las
mujeres más amadas del Reino Unido
además de Isabel segunda evidentemente
que es la princesa Diana Y bueno pues
justamente la mira que tiene todo el
pueblo británico es a esto ver cómo será
este gobierno de transición de Carlos
III que sin lugar a dudas ha hecho un
llamado a la unidad de toda la familia
lo hemos visto a lo largo de estos días
desde que le pidió incluso al príncipe
Harry y a Meghan markle que dejaron
atrás un poco pues todo esto conocido y
todas las diferencias que hay entre
ellos para unirse salir y darle también
el pésame a los británicos que están
perdiendo a su jefa de estado y Bueno
pues esta unidad que hay y que se está
viendo más que nunca reflejada aquí en
este funeral de estado en el que bueno
pues ya hacías cuenta de cómo se ha
seguido el protocolo tan directo como el
hecho de que no puedan utilizar
uniformes ni Harry ni Andrés porque ya
no son parte de la de la casa Real Como
miembrosinios por todos los escándalos
que los rodean Y bueno pues a pesar de
esto también se este sentimiento insisto
de la unidad que hay para hacerle frente
al futuro en un momento en el que
lanzamos Wolf está pasando por
decisiones Barbados acaba de declararse
Independiente entonces hay que mantener
a los estados que aún quedan dentro de
la mancomunidad de las Naciones
Empezando por Canadá con la presencia
importantísima de Justin trudea en este
funeral de estado se reunió ya con la
primera ministra y bueno Pues habrá que
enfrentar el futuro justamente Unidos y
de la mano para que logren pues mantener
el trono No nada más Carlos tercero
ahora sino para William y en un futuro
aún tanto lejano para el príncipe George
a quien vimos Por cierto en el funeral
de su gangan como él la llamaba
cariñosamente bueno y quiero
preguntarles sobre algo que usted ya
comenzó a mencionar y es el papel de la
monarquía británica en la web ya
hablábamos de la simbología política que
se ha utilizado en el funeral en un
intento de la realeza de decir aquí
seguimos presentes en la comonwealth
como de hecho permitir que una de sus
secretarias generales fuera la primera
mujer y la primera persona en hablar en
la iglesia y también con la policía
canadiense haciendo parte de la fuerza
real que escolta todo este cortejo
fúnebre sin embargo del otro lado varios
países de la como welft también han
aprovechado este momento histórico la
muerte de la reina Isabel para comenzar
a desligarse cada vez más de Reino Unido
Entonces en ese sentido que representa
este momento bisagra tanto para Reino
Unido como para los países de la comuna
web
justamente estamos hablando de este
momento en el que Carlos III tendrá que
poner su mira en acercarse muchísimo más
a los gobiernos que forman parte de la
mancomunidad esto se había logrado
Gracias a que Isabel como lo decía ya tu
corresponsal Bueno pues con una reina
viajera y no le importaba acudir a
África las veces que fuera necesario o a
cualquier país de la mancomunidad
Incluso en un momento muy interesante
bailó con uno de los líderes de la
mancomunidad
de África y que bueno pues esto fue sin
precedentes fue la primera vez que una
soberana bailaba con alguien en África y
Bueno pues realmente esto hablaba del
compromiso que tenía Isabel y que ahora
tiene que continuar Carlos III tiene que
mantener esta unidad tiene que acercarse
muchísimo más a los miembros de la
mancomunidad justamente para preservar
estas coronas y estos territorios de
ultramar y que no se puede lograr de
otra manera más que así generando
consensos generando ideas que apoyen y
que hagan una conexión directa con estos
líderes que hoy por hoy insistimos están
incluso la independencia en Canadá se
mandaba un mensaje muy claro en el que
se decía amábamos a la Reina Isabel a la
monarquía no tanto entonces creo que
justamente habrá que dedicarle muchísimo
más tiempo a la mancomunidad acudir a
los países estar presente con la gente
ser este puente esta conexión que fue
una sed que Isabel segunda logró
desarrollar durante mucho tiempo durante
su reinado estar presente en la
mancomunidad hay de viaje conociendo
directamente al pueblo para que la
saluden para que estén pendientes para
descubran en ella y ahora más bien
descubran en Carlos III este liderazgo
que está entrando será esta posición la
que él debe de tomar la importancia
geopolítica del imperio sigue siendo
importantísima y este tipo de despliegue
militar Y este funeral de estado lo está
probando creo que es una también de las
de las virtudes que tiene el despedir a
la Reina Isabel con esta magnitud para
seguir demostrando la importancia en el
Imperio y esta importancia concretamente
de la Reina Isabel no solo ha sido en
los países de la como web y lo vemos por
ejemplo con el hecho de una
participación histórica de líderes de
estado en un cortejo fúnebre para un
monarca británico pues tenemos más de
500 jefes de estado y presidentes y
primeros ministros participando en él
cuéntenos Entonces qué hizo tan especial
a la Reina Isabel II en la comunidad
internacional
yo creo que ha sido una mujer sin la
cual no se puede definir el siglo XX Y
por supuesto los primeros 20 años del
Siglo 21 la importancia que ella tenía
es que era una figura Más allá de
representación que sí logró esta otra
parte tan importante para El Monarca
británico que se establecer esta este
lazo este punto de mediación entre el
Primer Ministro y la gente que se
encuentra alrededor del gobierno que
está formado en su nombre y creo que
Isabel segunda logró también más que
nada tejer lazos de amistad lo decían Ya
esta amistad que tenía por ejemplo con
los Obama que también se extendió con
Joe biden habrá que recordar que en su
momento Isabel segunda le dijo a Justin
trudó que iba a ser Primer Ministro en
algún momento de Canadá tuvo boca de
profeta y eso la acercó sin lugar a duda
hasta los líderes que hoy están
presentes allá en Reino Unido
despidiéndola y bueno evidentemente la
importancia de ser una mujer que estuvo
presente durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial que se convirtió en mecánica
para ayudar al pueblo británico que
participó durante mucho tiempo de las
actividades para poder es salvaguardar
el bienestar de los británicos Durante
este tiempo tan convulso que fue la
Segunda Guerra Mundial eso le permitió
establecer conexiones con la gente que
le permitió establecer también lazos que
son muy fuertes y que son difíciles de
romper y que siento que precisamente
justamente es lo que estamos viendo hoy
el amor la gratitud el agradecimiento
que le tiene todo su pueblo precisamente
por haberse entregado tan de lleno y
haber cumplido con su función como lo
decía en aquel discurso histórico a sus
21 años mi vida se alarga o corta estará
dedicada a servir a esta familia
Imperial de la que todos formamos parte
y lo cumplió sin lugar a dudas todavía
dos días antes de morir recibió a su
quinceava primera ministra y esto habla
del compromiso que tenía y evidentemente
esto se traduce en el amor y en la
gratitud que estamos viendo hoy en las
calles de Londres pero también en el
retome que tiene la noticia a nivel
internacional hemos hablado sí en cada
uno de los medios en Estados Unidos
ahora con ustedes en Colombia su
importancia era mundial